Leute, also wenn das nicht Skamars ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Da schreit schon Skamars, aus allen Ecken schreit da Skamars.
Ich meine, was soll das für Blödsinn?
Das Wearable, das ihnen den Rücken frei hält.
Schlafen sie ein, ohne Schäfchen zu...
Okay, was?
Oh Gott, das ist Amazon Skamars.
Du Do, Einschlafhilfe, schon mehr als 150.000 Benutzer schlafen schneller ein.
Immer wenn sowas dahinter steht, bin ich ja skeptisch.
Das wird nicht dampfen.
Was, was, was?
Ein Lichtmetronom.
What?
Egal, ich muss im Kreis laufen jetzt.
Oh ne, ist die Map zugegangen?
Hm, hatten wir noch eine Map auf?
Ne, ich glaube wir hatten keine Map.
Schaut mal auf.
Machen wir mal ein bisschen was, ein bisschen was.
Ein bisschen was anspruchsvolleres.
Easy.
Aber eigentlich noch ein bisschen ist frei.
California.
Oder auch nicht.
Ach jetzt.
California.
Best thing.
Oh Gott, ein Summoner-Bild.
Ich bin kack-noob, ich darf das.
Ich hab fünf Jahre nicht gespielt.
Und das ist meine erste League wieder.
Und ich hab...
Ich hab auch mit einem Nicht-Summoner-Bild angefangen.
Und hab festgestellt, dass Nicht-Summoner-Bilds erstens anstrengend sind.
Das wäre nicht das Problem gewesen.
Und zweitens viel mehr Einsatz brauchen.
Sowohl was, also erstens was Spielzeit angeht, was Currency angeht, was alles angeht.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach jetzt einfach Easy-Mode und Spiel Summoner-Bild.
Was zum Einsteigen gut ist, finde ich.
Oder kann ich allgemein auch nur empfehlen, weil das Spiel überfordert einen total.
Wenn man neu ist.
Ich mein, ich hab den Vorteil gehabt, ich hab das vor fünf Jahren schon mal relativ viel gespielt.
Das heißt, die grundsätzlichen Sachen kannte ich.
Aber ich hab überhaupt keinen Plan mehr, die ganzen neuen Sachen, die sie eingeführt haben.
Und ich checke die Hälfte der Gegenstände immer noch nicht.
Ähm, was es jetzt an Crafting-Materialien gibt.
Alter, wie es ruckelt.
Wie es ruckelt.
Du bist auch ein Kapp'n, du würdest es nicht spielen.
Ja.
Es hat jeder so seine Präsenz.
Mich juckt das nicht.
Aber ich hab mit MMOs auch immer keine Probleme gehabt, OP-Bilds zu spielen.
Außerdem ist das super, wenn man nebenbei spielen will und Chat lesen mag.
Erstmal ein Webinar für PoE belegen.
Ist echt so.
Also, man müsste mal irgendwie einer der...
Oder man müsste mal einen von den guten Content-Bilds,
guten Content-Creator und Streamer
überlegen. Die sollen einen Udemy-Kurs
machen. Die sollen per
Sovex einen Udemy-Kurs machen. Das würde ich garantiert
Leute kaufen.
Garantiert. Das Game ist so komplex
mittlerweile, was es da alles
gibt. Die sollen einen Udemy-Kurs
machen.
Oh, was ist das da für ein Ding?
Das ist irgendwas, was Damage macht.
Was ist das?
Da mag ich.
Hallo, Mobs.
Mobs, Mobs. Ihr schlagt auf den
Falschen. Ihr müsst auf den.
Achso, da sind schon so viele Mobs drauf.
Easy. Von wegen, der kann was.
Easy-Summoner-Bild.
Da kann es
nichts schief gehen.
Take notes in chat.
Es ist wirklich übelst kompliziert.
Okay, jetzt ist
nichts getroppt, was ich nicht kapiere.
Das hat zwar viel drauf,
aber nur low rolls.
Das suckt.
Übrigens, hier. Jetzt kann ich noch mal
mein Pro-Tool anwerfen. Bam.
Was könnte es wohl ungefähr wert sein?
Nichts. Nice.
Das ist aber nicht wirklich akkurat.
Easy-Map fertig.
Hier nochmal den Ring aufheben.
Und nochmal
den Metamorph bashen.
In der Hoffnung, der wird nicht zu OP jetzt.
Oh, der hält ganz gut was aus.
Oh, Hände hoch, Leute.
Easy. Hände hoch.
Oh, fuck.
Bitte um. Bitte um.
Das ist so ein richtiges
Face-Roll-Bild, ja.
Richtig zum Face-Rollen.
Oh, da ist noch Zeug.
Wow, Alter.
Jetzt. Mein Rechner.
Ich hab 5 FPS.
Kann es mal sterben?
Alter, was ist da oben los?
Oh, jetzt ist Haste am Start.
What the fuck?
Alter.
Was ist jetzt los?
Meine OP-Monser,
sind nicht stark genug.
Für Haste.
Doch, jetzt. Jetzt Easy-Mode.
Oh.
Was haben wir selbst gemacht davon?
Nichts. So muss das sein.
Haben wir getroppt.
Ein Herz.
Ein Riegel. Oh, Dingsding.
Naja.
Elching-Grenzen.
Wir könnten mal gucken, ob wir vielleicht Zutaten haben,
um uns einen Custom-Metamorph zusammenzubasteln.
Kannst du auf Stadia spielen?
Oh, je.
Okay. Ich glaube, das wäre krass.
Ey, da würde ich auch ausflippen.
Es ist zwar prinzipiell ein Game, wo ich sagen würde,
es eignet sich für Stadia ganz gut,
weil das ist kein Shooter oder so.
Aber...
Ich glaube, Input-Lag ist hier übelst nervig.
Ich glaube, Input-Lag ist echt nervig.
Wenn man das über Stadia spielt,
gibt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht auf Stadia.
Ich mache mir jetzt in letzter Zeit immer mal den Spaß dran
und suche mal nach Stadia.
Stadia, äh, äh, Store.
Können wir mal reingucken, was da, was ist da?
Games.
So.
Moment.
Sie...
Ist das immer noch alles eine Game-Auswahl?
Ernsthaft?
Es gibt...
Das ist doch bestimmt...
Das glaube ich nicht, oder?
Das ist doch...
Das kann nicht alles sein.
Ist das immer noch alles?
Das ist doch lächerlich.
Den Scheiß stellen die morgen ein.
Game-List.
Nee, das ist alles.
Superhot.
Das ist wirklich alles.
Wer soll denn den...
Alter, wer kauft sich das denn?
Sowas Sinnloses.
So ein Typ...
So richtig typisches Google-Rohrkrepierer-Produkt wieder, ey.
Wer...
Wer kauft sich den Kram denn?
The fuck?
Ihr habt vor allem Baldur's Gate 3, ne?
Noch nicht mal ansatzweise raus.
Mal gucken, wann das überhaupt rauskommt.
Gibt's dazu schon Release-Date?
Zumindest haben sie definitiv, das sage ich ja auch nicht oft, das richtige Studio dafür gewonnen für Baldur's Gate 3.
Cyberpunk ist auch noch nicht raus, ja.
Na gut, die müssen ja irgendwas da drauf anzeigen.
Ich meine, stellt euch mal vor, die machen Baldur's Gate 3 weg, Cyberpunk weg, Doom Eternal weg.
Das ist ja ein Witz.
Das meiste...
Die Top-Games hier auf den ersten...
Es sind in den ersten...
Von den ersten acht Spielen, die die Top-Games darstellen, sind drei Stück noch nicht erschienen.
Das ist doch heftig, oder?
Was, Google?
Ich überleg mir die ganze Zeit, warum kann man sich nicht einfach den Store angucken?
Die Sache ist die...
Das ist alles, was im Store drin ist.
Das ist alles, was im Store drin ist, anscheinend.
Was?
Stadia Smith's Day?
This year?
Hm...
Das erscheint mir aber ziemlich...
Okay, wann soll das rauskommen?
Every...
Was?
To release...
Everywhere?
In zwei...
Was ist denn das für ein Satz?
Ach so, ich wurde surprise...
Irgendwann...
Das würde mich auch überraschen, wenn das noch 2020 kommt.
Das ist der Witz.
Äh...
Stadia Shop...
Haben die eine Shop-Uhr?
Nee, das ist die Games.
Das ist die offizielle Stadia Games List.
Wollen die uns eigentlich verarschen bei Google?
Ernst gemeinte Frage.
Wollen die uns verarschen?
Ich meine, die Leute, die sich eine Founders Edition gekauft haben, die haben den Kram ja glücklicherweise noch abgestellt, die kommen sich doch komplett verarscht vor.
Geht...
Ähm...
Äh...
Geht eigentlich...
Chrome mittlerweile?
Play Stadia on Chrome.
Anscheinend.
Beinau.
Die...
Warum...
Warum tun die so, als muss ich mir das kaufen?
Ich brauch doch einfach nur...
Ich brauch doch einfach nur Chrome.
Sign in?
Sign up?
Geht...
Geht das überhaupt in Chrome schon?
Also für mich ist das nicht ersichtlich, ob das in Chrome funktioniert.
Ne, für Updates.
Wie...
Wie spiele ich den Scheiß in Chrome?
Hier, Sign in.
Okay, ich guck...
Ich guck...
...
man da okay wo ist das du hast mich bei mir wieder gewinnt spiel als freunde ach
du meinst auf twitch auf twitter freund habe ich gelesen habe ich habe ich
gesehen habe ich gesehen so moment erst mal erst mal zeug
beschwören frau tage hieß also ich will den afrikaner getrennt nicht das
skelett auf geht's
sie der kann ja gar nichts
ordentlich drops erst mal alles krämmen was irgendwie
halbwegs sinnvoll aussieht wünsche uns glück sie mit wieso gewinne ich dann
auch was weil du uns da eingetragen hast
oder ist es dieses komische gewinnspiel wo es darum ging man muss einfach leute
erwähnen die auch so hype sind auf google endlich auf google auf die force
und gedöns
das ist zu viel da was haben wir hier das ist grab haben wir hier das ist auch
grab und liegen noch paar coins aber da
ludludlud
mal gespannt
gar nicht so schlecht aber nichts überragendes
das ist wahrscheinlich ziemlicher krepp aber eins habe ich schon gecheckt items
mit diesen diesen support ding an drauf also quasi dass das irgendwelche auch in
auslöst spez auslöst oder irgendwelche was sie passiven gems drin hat die haben
das Potenzial relativ viel wert zu sein.
Allerdings hat es Crap Rolls.
Äh, das ist Müll.
Alles nix
Gescheites.
Äh, alles
weg damit.
Hallo? Altsch.
Ich glaub, die hab ich nämlich
noch nicht.
Doch, hab ich schon.
Was hat man
eigentlich davon? Mal Frage an die
Kenner. Bringt das überhaupt was, wenn man
jeden einzelnen Node hier füllt?
Und...
Oder besser gesagt,
muss man das vielleicht sogar machen?
Ich vermute mal, dass man das
machen muss. Aber so ganz sicher bin
ich mir da nicht bei.
Wie ist Car Speed?
Ah ja, machen wir mal.
Ih, ne Waldmap.
Monka.
Jetzt so Wolzen raus
aus dem Papier. Wolzen hat mich nicht angesprochen.
Vor allem durch die ganzen Bugs nicht.
Ah, der Boss
ist gespawnt.
Ich hab bei Dance Gaming
ein bisschen geguckt. Das erste, was ich
bei Wolzen, Wolzen, wie spricht man das eigentlich
genau aus, äh, gesehen hab, ist, dass
sie eben den Story Progress gesettet haben
von Akt 3 auf Akt 2 zurück.
Durch den Wack.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, ach, weißt du was, warten wir das
Ganze mal ab. Zumal es mit Wolzen wohl
Endgame-mäßig auch noch ziemlich dünn
aussieht und auch keine klare
Strategie da ist. Ich warte mal ab.
Wie gesagt, ich hab Pest und Wechsel
am Anfang gespielt, zwischendurch ein bisschen
und jetzt nach 5 Jahren wieder
und da hat sich wenigstens ordentlich was
getan. Also bis die, bis Wolzen
da in die Nähe kommt an Content, wird noch eine
ganze Weile dauern.
Zumal ja auch demnächst
Pest und Wechsel 2 am Start ist.
In einem Jahr, genau,
genau, so werd ich das machen.
In einem Jahr ist es erstens wahrscheinlich runtergesetzt,
was mir, was mir persönlich
eigentlich ziemlich wurscht ist, aber
ähm, man sieht dann eben,
ob das Spiel halt schon
dead ist oder, oder nicht.
Und angeblich muss es ja zumindest
laut der GameStar, den kann man zwar auch nicht so
immer alles glauben, aber solche, sagen wir mal so,
solche einfachen Sachen schon,
muss das ja wohl ein absolut katastrophaler
Start gewesen sein bei Wolzen.
Also mit Online-Modus,
die nicht funktionieren.
Krassen, also übertrieben
krassen Progress-Bugs.
Wo geht's denn hier rein?
Was macht das eigentlich? Chaos-Orbs?
Weiß, kann man nie genug haben.
In einem Jahr ist vielleicht mal
fertig. Man darf ja nicht vergessen, Wolzen
war ja schon, wie jetzt eigentlich?
Wolzen oder Wolzen?
Nicht, dass ich das mal doppelt aussprechen muss.
Life to Swift.
Das bringt ihm gegen
Kreisspieler an Skelette auch nichts, dass er Swift ist.
Wo ist mein
Metamorph, Dude?
Guck mal her.
Colonies, Colonies, Colonies, perfekt.
Wolzen, also.
Okay.
Oder Wolzen.
Moment, warum stirbt der nicht?
Der lebt noch.
Der darf nicht. Ah, jetzt.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist eine Sache, die habe ich halt
in Path of Exile auch noch überhaupt nicht drauf,
zu erkennen.
Welche Unix was sind? Man erkennt das ja an den
Skins, obwohl man die, also, bevor man
die...
Okay, der Crap ist nix wert.
Der Crap ist nix wert.
So, erstmal hier die Trading-Seite aufmachen und gucken.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist der Crap
überhaupt nix wert.
Näh, nix.
Überhaupt nix wert.
Aber die meisten Unix sind in Path of Exile
irgendwie nix wert.
Mal frage an die Kenner, welche Unix sind denn überhaupt
was wert? Gibt's überhaupt welche?
Also ich weiß, dass Dings hier, Tabula Rasa
ist was wert.
Weil halt Level-Item, schlechthin.
Ansonsten, was gibt's
für, was gibt's für
für Unix,
die ja was wert sind? Die meisten Unix sind nix wert.
Headhunter,
ja gut, Headhunter ist das krasse Gegenbeispiel.
Headhunter ist halt auch ultra-rare
und mit das
braunste Item im Game.
Aber mal außer Headhunter,
wo du ja quasi
erstmal den Teufel beschwören musst,
dass du überhaupt eine Chance hast, dass das droppt
und die Sterne in der
richtigen Konstellation stehen müssen.
Aber
was gibt's denn da sonst noch?
Bei dem Crap kann man gleich verkaufen.
Oh nee!
Ich bin jetzt reingelaufen.
Unix-Items.
Stream lag auch nicht schon wieder.
Okay,
Unity-Media ist wieder, hat wieder zugeschlagen.
Leute, es liegt nicht an mir.
Es liegt offensichtlich an Unity-Media.
Dann wird das heute
mit Game-Streamen wohl
eher nix.
Unity-Media mag
das nicht.
Dann machen wir jetzt was anderes.
Nachdem Unity-Media
keinen Bock hat, heute,
dass wir streamen können,
wie man hier sieht,
was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Oh, fuck.
Was hab ich denn jetzt getrieben hier?
Ich hab das irgendwie umgestellt
und ich weiß nicht, wie ich das wieder zurückstelle.
Stell ich das wieder zurück?
Mann, ist nicht schlimm, aber
Unity-Media gibt's
mir vollkommen wurscht.
Mein Vertrag ist noch mit Unity-Media.
Es ist jetzt Wohler vorn, aber egal ob Unity-Media
oder Wohler vorn, kriegt von mir wieder den Haufen.
Ich stell mal auf
Just Chatting um.
Vielen wird's ja anscheinend nix, danke.
Vodafone.
Aber jetzt Chillzor-Technik-Talk
ohne Path of Exile.
Weil ich ja gerne auch ein bisschen im Kreis
kreiten würde, ne?
Unix sind meistens einfach nur gute Leveling-Items,
bis man genug gefarmt hat und bessere...
Ja.
Es gibt ein paar Bills im Forum,
hab ich schon gesehen, die spezielle Unix
verwenden, auch im Endgame, aber wirklich
teuer ist davon eigentlich nix, was ja gut ist
im Endeffekt.
So kann man sich das einfach kaufen, weil, wie gesagt,
weil Farmen, wenn man schon
eine League spielt, wo man traden kann,
dann muss man sich in Kammer nicht
erfarmen.
Äh, das spackt immer noch rum.
Hier unten. Ich seh's ja,
es spackt immer noch rum.
Also wenn das nicht besser wird,
bei Unity-Media,
beziehungsweise Wohler vorn,
dann müssen wir mal wieder
übelst flamen
auf Twitter.
Denkt daran, Unity-Media ist jetzt
unter vorn.
Kommt mit uns in die Service-Zukunft.
Leute, so
sieht die Service-Zukunft aus.
Also
wer sich gefragt hat, wie sieht die Service-Zukunft
aus? Framedrops.
Huge IQ
Unity-Media. Perfekt.
Leute, ich kann mich nicht
zurückhalten. Anzeige
geht's raus, ich weiß, direkt
kommen die Feministen an.
Die waren
einfach dazu gepasst, irgendwie.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal Wohler vorn
Services an.
Auf dem großen Unpacked Event,
das geht mir nicht auf den Sack. Ich will einfach, dass der Scheiß
funktioniert.
Ich brauch noch nicht mal hier dieses krasse Multitasking
wie der Opa auf der Seite.
Ich brauch kein Handy, kein Telefon,
keine Fernbedienung mit Fernseher, kein Notebook
auf dem Schoß. Ich brauch einfach einen
funktionierenden Upload, den ich
ja auch noch... Ich bezahle, die haben mich ja
halb skamast
bei Unity-Media. Ich bezahle ja
meinen Upload doppelt.
Ich bezahle Power-Upload
und ich bezahle Power-Upload. Ich bezahle
zweimal Power-Upload. Ich bezahle
einmal Power-Upload für Power-Upload
zu haben und bezahle nochmal Power-Upload
für richtiges, echtes
Dual-Stack zu haben.
Also richtig, richtig huge skamast.
Ach, manch...
Läuft's jetzt
eigentlich? Nee.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich flame die jetzt.
Ich flame die jetzt auf Twitter.
Und zwar...
Wen
sollen wir flamen?
Wollen wir Vodafone Service flamen?
Oder noch Unity-Media Hilfe?
Unity-Media hat
die Art... Ey, ich schreib einfach beide an.
Na klar. Unity-Media
hat den Vorteil, dass die meine
Daten haben und ich sie nicht wieder
posten muss.
Warum krieg ich eigentlich so viele
Twitter-Posts von MontanaBlack
empfohlen?
Ich folge ihm nicht.
Ich hab eigentlich mit ihm überhaupt nichts
zu tun.
Okay, also wir schreiben jetzt...
Add... Wie heißen die?
Unity-Media
Hilfe
und Add...
Wie hießen die anderen? Vodafone Hilfe?
Ups.
Ich hab aus Versehen abgeschickt.
LOL
Ich hab
eine leere Nachricht abgeschickt.
Äh, wie hieß die?
Vodafone Service.
Okay, also...
Was schreiben wir jetzt?
Frametrops...
Ich kann ja nicht Frametrops schreiben.
Da sitzt der Service-Mensch davor
und überlegt sich erst einmal...
Hm... Von was redet er denn?
Hat er schon mal seinen Router neu
gestartet vielleicht?
Weil wir wissen ja bekanntlicherweise, beim Support
ist Router neu starten das Mittel
der Wahl. Ohne Router neu starten tut sich ja da...
tut sich da nichts.
Router muss neu gestartet werden.
Okay, wir schreiben jetzt genau.
Wir schreiben jetzt...
Seit heute Abend
Abend
kein
Stream möglich.
Kackt
alle 5 Min ab
und die Bandbreite
bricht ein.
So.
Bam. Abgeschickt.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, ob da noch eine Arbeit
bei denen ist.
Ich glaube ja nicht so spät.
Ich erwarte
das auch gar nicht.
Mal gucken, ob da jetzt noch eine Antwort
drauf kommt.
Ich hoffe die schreiben nicht public meine Kundennummer oder sowas.
Aber sowas sind sie eigentlich immer
vorsichtig.
Man muss auch
sagen, der Twitter Support gibt sich
immer viel Mühe.
Die können dann auch letztendlich nichts machen.
Verlorene Pakete...
Tja...
Genau habe ich das alles nicht analysiert.
Weil es nur...
Also ja, natürlich.
Unterm Strich schon.
Weil es nur, dass definitiv irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Und das liegt nicht an Unity Media...
Äh, das liegt nicht an Twitch.
Das liegt nicht an mir, sondern das liegt auf dem Weg dahin bei Unity Media.
Wo davon ist das neue Hermes,
was Paketverlust angeht?
Ich hatte mit Hermes noch nie Paketverlust.
Hattest du mit Hermes
schon mal Paketverlust?
Wo ist der Sibaro?
Wo ist der Sibaro eigentlich?
Gigabit Cable.
Tarife.
Schauen wir mal.
CableMax, das ist doch was für mich.
Und Max, was hast du für Inhalte?
Natürlich CableMax.
Ich glaube, ich sollte ihnen mal vorschlagen,
wir sollten uns zusammentun.
Das passt einfach zu gut.
Die sollen mir mal CableMax
sponsoren.
Und dann, äh,
erzähle ich im Stream auch immer, wie gut
Unity Media CableMax ist.
Posht die Telekom aber nicht wie verrückt
Super Vectoring. Ja doch!
Weil die Telekom noch auf
Teufel komm raus ihren alten Kupfer-
Kram halt an den Mann bringen will.
Die haben ja auch keine Wahl.
Sollte sie auch machen.
Äh, und was kostet
das jetzt? Oder wo sieht man jetzt, was es ist?
Was? Alter, was ist
mit euch los? Seht ihr das hier?
Moment.
Was ist denn das für ein beknacktes Verhältnis?
1000 M down, 50 ab.
Das wird ernsthaft, ja.
Was haben die alle
gesoffen eigentlich?
Was, was ist...
Wollen wir mit einem Experte
sprechen?
Was könnten wir den Experten denn fragen?
Ach nee!
Ach nee, geht gar nicht.
Ach, oh Mann.
Oh, das ist ja doof.
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt so ein Chatbot
oder sowas.
Eigentlich wollte ich den Experten erstmal
fragen. Geh weg!
Warum kann man nicht einfach auf die Seite klicken, ohne dass was passiert?
Ich wollte den Experten fragen,
was mache ich, wenn ich mehr Upload haben will?
Und dann wollte ich
den Experten fragen, ob er mir erklären kann, was
Dual Stack Lite ist.
Ich mein, okay.
50 Mbit, wenn man mal
ehrlich ist, sind 50 Mbit wirklich gut.
Aber das Verhältnis
von 1000 zu 50
ist halt schon der Witz.
Das reicht ja gerade mal aus,
dass wenn du
TCP-Bestätigungspakete verschickst,
dass quasi für vollen Download
die Bestätigungspakete
verschickt werden können.
So über den Daumen gepeilt.
Ja, ich will mit dem Experten sprechen.
Aber geht ja nicht.
Siehst du uns schon?
Ich sehe meinen Berater im Browser.
Ich will gar nicht
so viel zwischenmenschliche Interaktion.
So ein Chat-Fenster würde mir voll und ganz reichen.
Live-Chat?
Ne, wo?
Wo habe ich Live-Chat?
Ich sehe kein Live-Chat.
Nur bis 20 Uhr. Wir haben 21.30 Uhr
kein Live-Chat.
Da gibt es ein Live-Chat, was?
Wo?
Ihr seht mehr als ich.
Chat.
Oh, wo davon hat geantwortet?
Sende mir
mal bitte deine Handynummer per
DM.
Warum zum Geier
braucht er meine Handynummer?
Ich sehe gerade, dass die Werte
echt nur semi-gut sind.
Sende mir mal bitte deine Handynummer.
Okay.
Wo habe ich mein Handy?
Wartet mal.
Ich hole mal kurz mein Handy.
Okay.
Jetzt liegen. Nein, nicht liegen.
Für irgendwas muss ich
lohnen, dass ich einen zweiten Monitor habe, oder?
Was bedeutet eigentlich, die Werte sind
semi-gut?
Schicke ich ihm das mal.
Eine Sache, die mich am iPhone
immer verwirrt ist,
wie findet man im iPhone seine eigene Nummer?
Jetzt ernst gemeinte Frage.
Gibt es einen Trick, wie man im iPhone
seine eigene Nummer gut und einfach
findet?
Kontakte. Ja, Kontakte bin ich. Und dann?
Oben?
Meine Karte.
Steht da.
Ah.
Meine Güte.
Chat.
Huge.
Oh, Christine antwortet uns.
Dann ist alles gut.
Ich bin Fan von Christine.
Dann, da sind wir in guten Händen.
Zeig mal, was weiß ich,
wie Christine ausschaut.
Keine Ahnung.
Kompetent.
Okay.
PN?
Handy-Nummer.
Gut, ist raus.
Handy-Nummer
ist raus.
Komm, Christine kriegt jetzt auch
das passende Emoji als
Antwort,
weil wir uns ja freuen, dass sich jemand drum
kümmert.
Was? Ich kann
keine Emojis kopieren. Warum nicht?
Warum kann ich?
Das geht nicht.
Das ist nicht
legal.
Die Omaschine.
Alter, der Twitch-Chat wieder.
Der Chat.
Ihr seid...
Christine guckt bestimmt
gerade den Stream. Wenn das so wäre,
wäre ja witzig.
Moin, Christine. Falls du zuguckst.
Ich glaub's ja eher nicht.
So, Leute. Wir warten jetzt mal, bis sie sich rühren
bei Unity Media bzw. Vodafone. Ich muss mich da immer
noch dran gewöhnen. Wisst ihr was bei uns in
Frank... Ich frag mich gerade, was die machen.
Google Maps
Frankfurt. Bei uns
ist es so, dass Vodafone
und Unity Media direkt gegenüber einen Shop
haben. Nicht Willy Brandt Platz.
Schweizer Platz.
Die müssten doch dann dicht machen.
Hier ist nämlich...
Wo macht man die Satellitenansicht?
Hier oben ist
nämlich... Warte mal, wo geht's? Zum Südbahnhof?
Hier geht's zum Südbahnhof.
Hier oben ist nämlich...
direkt gegenüber
Unity Media Store
und hier ist...
irgendwo...
Vodafone... Ach, Moment.
Telekom Store?
Ich glaube, ich verwechsel das jetzt.
Das ist in Unity Media und
Telekom Store. Ah, okay.
Na dann passt das.
Ja, den habe ich letztens sogar gesehen.
Ja, irgendwo.
Südbahnhof.
Ich laufe
hier lang.
Hier irgendwo. Irgendwo hier
auf der Ecke habe ich den letztens gesehen.
Held der Steine.
Wo ist denn hier?
Frankfurt Vodafones
Shop.
Ach, da oben.
Moment, ist hier nicht
irgendwo auch der Apple?
Der Apple Store? Der Apple Store ist doch ja auch so.
Ist doch auch da oben irgendwo.
Apple.
Ah, genau.
Genau, da ist nämlich auch...
Ne, das ist...
Ich kann mich immer bei Frankfurt in der Vogelperspektive
überhaupt nicht orientieren.
Ich dachte, er war irgendwo bei der Goethestraße.
Goethestraße.
Louis Vuitton Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Einzigen Haftbefehl-Lyrics,
die ich kenne.
Und nicht mal, weil sie gut sind,
sondern einfach nur, weil es in Frankfurt
und die Straße geht, wo ich quasi jeden Tag
durchlaufe.
Tja, Leute, warten wir mal ab, was Unity Media
so treibt.
Tun nicht so, als wären das die einzigen.
Doch, sind die einzigen.
Was kann ich denn sonst noch?
Äh...
Nix?
Ich glaub, kann ich nix.
Übrigens, ich hatte letztens...
Das muss ich jetzt mal erzählen.
Es kann sein,
dass wir letztens
mit Haftbefehl zusammen mexikanisch essen waren.
So bescheuert das jetzt klingt.
Also, ich meine, ich wusste nicht,
dass Haftbefehl ist.
Weil, ähm...
Moment, wo hab ich die Musik?
Machen wir nochmal an.
Wir sind hier letztens futtern gegangen.
Und zwar, ähm...
Mexikanisch.
So.
Wir sind letztens hier Mittagessen gegangen.
Ähm...
Und zwar...
Da.
Und als wir reingekommen sind,
waren die Verkäuferinnen überhaupt nicht ansprechbar.
Und ich hab dann irgendwann mitgekriegt,
dass die eine mit irgendeinem Typ,
was durchaus hätte
Haftbefehl sein können,
keine Ahnung, ich hab mir den nicht angeguckt,
Selfies gemacht hat.
Und als wir dann durchgelaufen sind,
haben die sich auch irgendwas von Haftbefehl
von Hafti Abi erzählt,
die Verkäuferin.
Und ich hab die dann gefragt,
wer war denn der...
Kennt man den?
Und ähm...
Der war...
War ja drei Meter groß.
Der war eigentlich ziemlich normal groß.
Sind die Toiletten immer noch im Keller?
Ich war noch nie auf dem Klo da.
Hafti Abi.
Also es kann durchaus sein,
dass ich sogar unbewusst
mit Haftbefehl mexikanisch essen war.
Also eigentlich ist mein Leben jetzt vorbei.
Ja?
Jetzt ist durch.
Ich hab sie leider nicht gefragt, wer das genau war.
Sie hat bloß gesagt, das war ein Deutschrapper.
Und dann meinte ich auch so, ja gut, äh...
Kann ich nicht mitreden.
Vielleicht...
Vielleicht war es doch irgendein anderer Typ.
Keine Ahnung.
Nicht, dass es jetzt einen großen Unterschied machen würde.
Gerüchte zufolge ist Haftbefehl
3,29 Meter groß.
Natürlich.
Und Montana Black ist wie alt?
24 oder so?
Ich kenn mich leider bei den
Montana Black Memes nicht so richtig aus.
Aber der ist doch...
Gibt doch irgendwie so ein Standardalter, was er ist.
Kenn ich nicht mehr.
Kenn ich mich nicht aus.
Oder war das Kronk, der 24 ist?
Geht alles, geht alles an mir vorbei.
Letztens hab ich wieder...
Ne, Kronk ist 12, genau.
Letztens hab ich ja mal wieder
die absolut geballte Intelligenz
auf Twitter gesehen.
Ich weiß, dass Kronk natürlich älter ist.
Ich weiß noch, dass Kronk nicht
Gregor Onk heißt.
Ähm...
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, ich hab letztens mal wieder
ein Lied empfohlen bekommen von Montana Black.
Da hat er sich irgendwie über...
Da hat er irgendeine
retweetet,
die angeblich...
Das ist so... Allein, was
ein Bullshit, mit was die Leute sich befassen
ist schon der Wahnsinn, ja?
Natürlich könnte man sich jetzt drüber lustig machen,
dass ich mich da drüber...
Nein, nein, der ist nicht 95.
Stimmt, mit 95, das meinte
ich genau. 95 Geburtsjahr,
das ist der Gag
immer gewesen. Ich weiß, der ist nicht so
viel jünger als ich.
Wir sind da nicht, wir sind altersmäßig nicht so
weit auseinander.
So, und da hat er irgendwie
eine retweetet,
da war die gesamte, die geballte Intelligenz
Ich zeige euch mal den Tweet.
Da war die geballte Intelligenz
von... auf Twitter
wieder am Start.
Ja. Da hat er
eine retweetet, die...
Oh ne!
Der Tweet ist weg.
Aber zumindest, Leute, wer mal wirklich
die komplette
geistige Unterschicht versammelt sehen
will, der liest sich die Antworten
durch.
Mir geht es gar nicht so sehr um den Tweet an sich, sondern um die Antworten.
Alter meine Güte, ey, die Leute.
Es ging irgendwie...
Er hat irgendwie eine retweetet, die
angeblich von Jesus in Hamburg
nachdem sie ihn nach einem Selfie
gefragt hat,
weggeschubst wurde.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, warum lese
ich so eine Scheiße überhaupt, ja?
Es geht mir eigentlich total
am Arsch vorbei.
Aber ich kann manchmal nicht
aufhören, entgegen besseren Wissens
mir dumme Kommentare auf Twitter durchzulesen
und danach wieder an der Welt zu verzweifeln
und mich zu wundern, wie dämlich
kann man im Kopf eigentlich sein?
Genau, von Jesus.
Wie spricht man den Typ eigentlich aus?
Gitzitz.
Die ist so ein Abfuck.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sich das geben kann.
Ja, genau, Halfcorn.
Genau, genau, genau.
Die Nachricht von dem Vodafone-Helfer ist ja voll korrekt.
Das ist doch gut.
Dafür ist er ja da.
Oder sie.
Ist ja Christine.
Frauenkontakt, Leute.
Huiuiui.
Jetzt wird es aber kritisch, langsam.
Guck mal, die Antworten.
Christian oder meine DM.
Wer erzählt mir nur bei ihm bei...
Na gut.
Manchmal hat es einen Vorteil,
wenn man ein paar Follower auf Twitter hat.
Jesus spricht, man sagt, was kann.
Meinetwegen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Es gibt nur eine Sache,
wo ich mich bei Deutschrap mit identifizieren kann
und das hat mit Deutschrap nichts zu tun.
Das liegt einfach an meinem Alter.
Genau, Kiokon weiß das noch.
Um was es ging.
So.
Machen wir eigentlich im Stream was,
außer auf Unity Media zu warten?
Gerade nicht wirklich, oder?
Die sind immer so glücklich,
die Leute, wenn sie den Kram verwenden.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die sind immer so happy.
Ist das wenigstens...
Das ist kein MacBook, Leute.
Kein MacBook.
Das ist aber nicht hipster genug.
Also, wenn der richtig cool wäre,
hätte er ein MacBook gehabt.
Reddit-Programmer-Humor.
Können wir machen.
Moment, ich habe mein Mauskabel
irgendwie unter dem Mauspad eingeklemmt.
Wie kriegt man das hin?
Das ist so ein Trick, wenn man den
reproduzierbar hinkriegen würde,
könnte man damit fast auftreten.
Wie habe ich das Kabel jetzt unter das Mauspad gekriegt,
ohne das Mauspad anzuheben?
So.
Nee, ist immer noch drunter.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Support-Leute glücklich sind
bei Unity Media.
Also generell glaube ich nicht, dass Support-Leute glücklich sind.
Das ist ja auch der Grund,
warum ich im Leben im Support
arbeiten möchte.
Ich habe ja letztens wieder etwas gepostet,
was ich mitgekriegt habe beim Support.
Ja.
Genau.
Hat einer angerufen,
höchste Priorität,
unser Abrechnungssystem geht nicht mehr.
Dann haben halt die Leute
vom Support gefragt,
wer sind sie überhaupt
und um was für ein System geht es?
Dann kam die super erhellende Antwort,
die super erhellende Antwort,
es geht um das System, was PDFs generiert.
Ah, yes.
Excellent Information.
Jetzt weiß man sofort Bescheid.
Sofort.
Entstört, noch während er anruft.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich nicht im Support arbeiten will.
Ich setze mich nicht gerne
mit Leuten auseinander
und das ist im Support ja
tagtäglich der Fall.
Stream ist jetzt komplett dead?
Oh.
Oh je.
Unity Media, please.
Was macht Unity Media?
Es geht wieder.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh je. Unity Media.
Come on, bra.
Ne, nicht bra.
Es ist ja Christine. Christine misst gerade irgendwas.
Stream läuft noch ohne Probleme.
Hast du aber Glück, dass es bei dir ohne Probleme klappt.
Im Support bekommt man die ganze Landung
menschlicher Dummheit.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen,
Christine hat was besseres zu tun
eigentlich als um
mit irgendeinem Spack von YouTube
beziehungsweise von Twitch
da
also quasi mit mir
um 21.45 Uhr
auf Twitter Support zu schreiben.
Die hat da eigentlich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Kann ich verstehen, hätte ich auch nicht.
Ich versuche immer nett zu den
Support Leuten zu sein.
Weil ich kann mich da gut reinversetzen,
und sagt.
Hahaha, so ein Alex.
Hahaha.
Du meinst so den richtigen Jesus.
Wie spricht man den Kerl eigentlich richtig aus?
Jesus, Jesus.
Style.
Ja, das habe ich nämlich gar nicht dazu erzählt.
Also, wo es ja um diese Selfie ging,
diese Twitter Meldung,
die ich da gesehen habe,
da muss er wohl geantwortet haben,
so nach dem Motto,
Selfie gibts nur gegen Dreier mit deiner Freundin.
Und dann hat
sich halt
das Mädel
erdreistet zu sagen, nein,
will sie nicht.
Und dann hat Jesus sie angeblich weggeschubst.
Sodass sie zwei Meter rückwärts getaumelt ist.
Es ist aus allen
Bereichen sehr theatralisch
berichtet, ja,
zwei Meter ist eine ganz schöne Entfernung.
Zutrauen
tue ich das den Leuten aber
ohne Probleme.
Okay, gucken wir mal ein bisschen Programmer Humor.
First Level Support
ist halt Idiotenfilter, ist tatsächlich so.
Der Typ ist
der mega Asiok.
Die ganzen
Deutschrap-Typen, ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht geben.
Echt nicht.
Da verlierst du echt jegliche
Gehirnzellen danach.
Sowohl von den Leuten an sich,
ich sag ja immer,
es ist nicht notwendig,
wenn einem die Musik gefällt, dass man quasi
den Leuten dahinter irgendwie
irgendwie folgt oder das weiter. Ne, also ich kann
durchaus sagen, hey, ich mag die Red Hot Chili Peppers,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was sie die letzten 30 Jahre getrieben haben.
Juckt mich nicht, ist mir auch wurscht.
Aber die Deutschrap-Typen,
die drängen sich ja quasi direkt
in die Öffentlichkeit immer. Wer war das mit der
Polizei, der sich dann entschuldigt hat danach?
Und übelst den Schwanz eingezogen hat?
Wer war das? War da auch letztens
irgendwas? Du scheiß
Fanboy. Was war das
noch wieder für einer? War er
das nicht auch? Ne, das war ein anderer.
Flair, Flair war
das, genau. Gibt immer noch
gute, die sind in den Hintergrund gerutscht.
Ja, leider. Es ist aber immer so,
dass Mainstream ist halt
der Bodensatz, in der Regel. In der Regel
ist Mainstream halt der absolute Shit.
Sowohl
von der musikalischen Qualität her,
als auch
irgendwie von den Leuten.
Es ist einfach nur Bullshit, ja.
Deswegen,
das einzig wahre
höre ich zum größten Teil eigentlich bloß Hardrock und Heavy Metal.
Beste. Ich mein,
da gibt's Leute wie Ozzy, die sich
noch mit einer Gehhilfe live auf die
Bühne stellen. Und irgendwie noch
einen Ton rauskriegen.
Ist nicht so wirklich meine Musik, aber
muss man, muss man Respekt
für haben. Es gibt bestimmt normale
Leute, auch bei Deutschrappern,
keine Frage. Natürlich.
Es sind, es sind halt wie
immer, so die, die 10,
15 Oberspasten,
die es halt für alle anderen versauen.
Eminem, Eminem kann ich mir auch
gut anhören. Ohne Scheiß.
Letztens, irgendwie 20 Jahre
oder so, gefühlt nix mehr mitgekriegt von dem Kerl.
Neues Album am Start.
Was mir gar nicht schlecht gefallen hat.
Obwohl ich, obwohl ich kein großer Hip-Hop
Fan bin. Wen ich auch ganz
gerne gehört hab, äh,
Hip-Hop mäßig, ist der,
der, der Linkin Park, äh,
MC, wie's so schön heißt.
Als der noch, ähm,
Sachen abseits von Linkin Park
gemacht hat. Den fand ich auch immer ganz nett.
Aber ich bin kein großer Hip-Hop
Fan. Ist, ist, ist halt
einfach nicht meins. Aber man muss
anerkennen, es gibt auch da ein paar gescheite Sachen.
Guck, guck mal so ein bisschen,
bisschen Programmerhumor an, bis der,
bis, äh,
das Team sich der Sache
angenommen hat. Oh, ich hab
ne, ich hab ne, ich hab ne Nachricht gekriegt von,
von, äh, Vodafone.
Lieber
Kunde,
Unity Media ist jetzt
Vodafone. Willkommen bei uns.
Perfekt.
Beste, bester Willkommensgrüß.
Erstmal Stream mal abkacken. Huge.
By the way, immer noch, ja.
Ähm, wir haben
Ihr Anliegen aufgenommen und melden uns
schnellstmöglich bei Ihnen.
Okay, das ist ja ne langweilige Message. Das, äh,
vielen geht, oh, die Technik ist
informiert. Haha, das
erinnert mich an. Ich habe die Technik
gerade informiert.
Du wirst per SMS auf dem Laufenden
gehalten. Liebste Grüße,
Christine. Oh ja, ich fang gleich an zu schwitzen, Leute.
Der Unity Media, oh nein,
sorry, der Vodafone Support.
Warum sieht's denn die? Weil das
wahrscheinlich Policy ist bei denen.
Techniker ist informiert.
Das erinnert mich auch an.
Aber es hat das letzte Mal auch funktioniert.
Techniker ist informiert.
Genau, feels wow, man.
Vodafone Christine.
Ich finde es top,
dass die um so, so, so. Das schreiben
wir da jetzt. Wir sind mal nett.
Wir sind mal nett.
Ich schreib Ihnen mal zurück.
Schön, dass ihr euch
auch um solche Uhrzeit noch
um Probleme kümmert.
Um
Probleme kümmert.
Schleimer.
Soll ich den Jesus-Style
machen? Soll ich sagen, 3er mit deiner Freundin
oder kein Tweet, oder was?
Nein, wir sind nett.
Ich bin ja auch wirklich froh, dass sie sich da drum kümmern.
Gut. Ähm,
ja, es ist fast 22 Uhr. Wir haben in diesem
Stream fast nichts gemacht, weil es halt
rumspackt.
Techniker sind informiert, ja.
Hallo Christine.
Schön, dass ihr euch noch um diese Uhrzeit
noch um Probleme kümmert.
Support-Mitarbeiter freuen sich auch,
wenn sie Leute sich freuen und sie nicht immer angeschissen werden.
Kann ich euch aus
eigener Erfahrung sagen. Ich bin zwar nicht im Support,
aber ich sitze nicht weit davon entfernt.
So.
Was haben wir, was haben wir denn hier? Gibt's
übrigens auch ein paar, ein paar Lulz,
bevor wir ins Bett gehen können?
Sie hat jetzt deine Nummer,
dann kann sie dir auch Ehre geben.
Ist klar.
Der Twitch Chat,
der Twitch Chat
Dating-Tipps, äh.
Da bist du verlassen,
wenn du dich auf den Twitch Chat verlässt.
Gibt's eigentlich irgendwas, worum
man sich auf den Twitch Chat verlassen kann?
Was hältst du von Shelly Cloud?
Top. Perfekt.
Das Beste.
Das Beste in dieser Kategorie.
Kannst du dir kaufen. Hab ich auch 15 Stück.
Aber nicht alle eingebaut. Beste.
Hab ich ja schon öfters gezeigt. Die Dinger.
Hab ich als Relay
für meine Lichtschalter.
Ich hab letztens einen ganz
merkwürdigen Channel
auf YouTube gefunden. Das muss ich euch
jetzt mal zeigen.
Wo es um das Thema Heimautomatisierung
ging. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr genau,
wie das, wie der Channel hieß.
Das war ein Channel,
die haben sich wirklich
legit, legit mit dem
Thema Heimautomatisierung
ähm,
beschäftigt, aber
es waren
sehr leicht
begleitete Mädels, die das Thema besprochen haben.
Und
mich hat's überrascht,
dass die Kombination aus wirklich seriösem
Inhalt und halbnackter
Mädels gerade im
Heimautomatisierungsbereich
auf YouTube irgendwie
zusammenfindet, ja.
Ähm, wie hieß das denn?
Man findet's bestimmt
relativ schnell, weil es viel... Ja!
Hier!
Fuck! Okay, hier haben sie ja noch...
Hey, what the fuck?
Oh, ich vergesse nicht, Opener, was ist da?
Also, das Video, was ich gesehen hab,
hatte so wenige an.
Wo ich mir gedacht hab, okay,
dieses Thema in Kombination hätte ich
jetzt nicht mit gerechnet.
Ähm,
weil jemand gefragt hat, was das ist.
Das ist ein Relay
für zum, also du kannst zum Beispiel
zwischen Schalter und, also zwischen,
ähm,
Lichtschalter und, äh,
Lampenfassung
schalten, beziehungsweise
eigentlich umgedreht, du schaltest dann, du schaltest
mit dem alten Lichtschalter nur noch das Relay
über den, also du schaltest mit dem Schalter
quasi einen Schalter,
ähm,
und das ist
halt richtig gut, weil
es ist klein,
es passt unterputzt in die, in die,
in die Dose, also das heißt, man kriegt das
hin, es ist halt auch der, der
Wife Acceptance Faktor ist
hoch, weil man sieht halt nix,
was ja für viele auch nicht unwichtig ist.
Die Firmware, mit dem das
ausgeliefert wird,
ist auch, äh, komplett offline fähig.
Ich hab's schon 50 Mal im Stream gesagt,
die Bezeichnung dieser Produkte
und die, die, die, ähm,
die URL,
die Domain ist komplett bescheuert.
Das große Herausstellungsmerkmal
bei, bei den Shelly Geräten ist, dass sie offline
funktionieren.
Und was machen sie? Eine Domain,
die alles andere aussieht als offline.
Wo denkt ihr,
woran denkt ihr bei Shelly.Cloud?
Ihr denkt doch bestimmt, wenn ihr
Shelly.Cloud lest als erstes,
ah, das ist bestimmt ein Produkt, was sich super
offline verwenden lässt, oder?
Weiß nicht, was sich da die Marketing
äh, Pros bei
Shelly so überlegt haben,
aber eines der,
wie gesagt, heraus, herausragende Merkmale
von den Shelly Sachen ist, dass die ne, dass die
erste so Open Source Firmware drauf haben,
die alles kann, was man so braucht und halt
offline funktioniert.
Und nur optional irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten kann.
Also warum es Shelly.Cloud ist,
ne.
Nein, ist es nicht, Halbkorn.
Das ist, das sind, das sind, äh,
Relays vom Strom,
unterputzt Stromschalt, äh,
Kram.
Naomi Wu, die kenn ich auch, für 3D-Trocker-Kram.
Ja. Die gibt's auch.
Es gibt viele Channels, Technik-Channels
mittlerweile. Was ich auch letztens gefunden hab,
ist, ich stoß da jetzt, und
bevor jetzt der erste wieder anfängt, ja, ja, Max,
hast du's gefunden, ja. Doch, ich stoße
tatsächlich immer zufällig auf solche,
auf solche merkwürdigen YouTube-Channels,
auch oftmals in der, oder was heißt
merkwürdig, ähm,
Channels, die erstmal, erstmal merkwürdig
anmuten, ja. Ähm,
Spezialist vs. Gamer.
Ja, vor, ist klar.
Weil der Spezialist
mit dem Controller in Call of Duty auch so
wahnsinnig own wird. Ähm,
denk ich's dir, letztens hab ich
ein Tasty PC.
Hab ich auch, ja, was?
Wtf geht da wieder ab?
Die flüstert dann auch noch,
die, die flüstert quasi so ASMR-Style
dann irgendwelche Grafikkartenspecs
und sowas ins Mikrofon, äh.
Was es nicht
alles gibt mittlerweile auf YouTube.
Und ich stolper wirklich immer
zufällig über solchen Content.
Chelly.local war schon für das lokale Netz
reserviert. Ja, .local
ist, glaub ich, auch keine gültige Top-Level-Domain.
Wobei
mittlerweile ja fast alles irgendwie
möglich ist in der Top-Level-Domain.
Dort, wo ich arbeite, wir haben eine eigene
Top-Level-Domain. Ich weiß nicht, wen wir dafür bestochen haben.
Wir haben eine eigene Top-Level-Domain.
Okay, mal gucken, ob wir noch was
zu lachen finden hier. Bevor wir
ins Bett müssen. Oder besser gesagt, wir.
Also,
eine Sache, die ich garantiert nie
machen werde, ist den Twitch-Chat mit
ins Bett nehmen.
Egal wie cute Chat
der Chat heute ist.
Guck mal, hat Christine noch mal
geantwortet?
Nee. Muss ich auch nicht. Äh, hat
sie schon gesagt.
Ich hab' nur
eine Frage.
Ich habe
mal
noch
ein paar
Fragen.
Ich habe
noch
ein paar
Fragen.
Ich
habe